welcome everyone to the first screencast
in our nlu and information retrieval
series
the goal of this introductory screencast
is twofold
i will first introduce the ir area
then i will discuss ways in which nlu
and ir can interact productively
and focus on how retrieval can be an
effective component in defining our
interview tasks and building our energy
systems
so what is information retrieval or ir
to a first approximation this is the
field concerned with search
the first example that typically comes
to mind is web search
but as we'll see today this field
extends richly beyond web search and has
strong connections to our work with mlu
let's now attempt to define ir more
formally
here is a simplified version of the
definition used by the introduction to
ir book by manningbittel
they define ir as the process of finding
material that fulfills an information
need from within a large collection of
unstructured documents
let's unpack this definition
starting on the left hand side here
the definition says that we're concerned
with finding material from a large
collection in other words large scale
search is at the essence of ir
on the right hand side the definition
restricts this to unstructured documents
basically items like text media and
products
ones that lack the clear-cut structure
of things like database tables or graphs
structure-based search or
structure-based traversal of graphs and
databases are not typically considered
ir problems for our purposes
although of course they are interesting
on their own right
this leads us to the term that was at
the center of our definition namely the
information
need it is difficult to think of ir
without thinking of the user at this at
the center of the system and
the information need is what the user
has in mind
to solve a task or otherwise
learn or reach the material that they're
looking for
the goal of a search system is thus to
identify and fulfill the user's
information need
so whatever we retrieve is only going to
be considered relevant to the extent
that it advances this goal
in most ir tasks the user will
explicitly provide us with a query that
summarizes and expresses that
information need
it is very important to note that this
query may contain ambiguity may miss
some important details or might even
sometimes ask the wrong question and
that's completely normal the user may
not even be sure what precisely they're
looking for that's why they're searching
for something
so we must rely on our knowledge of the
task and whatever we know about the user
within the constraints of our
application
in order to solve ir problems
the second thing is that typical
information needs vary by task
and so um you know the typical
information need that we have and how to
best interpret and deal with that these
are factors that vary greatly by task
and by collection type in ir i'll take
it you've already made the connection
between ir and searching the web
searching your email and also finding
files on your desktop
buried in deep folders or something
but there are plenty of other ir tasks
where search is crucial
for instance you might want to find
recent papers related to the birth paper
by devlin ital of course
this is not a
the best example because there are many
many papers related to birth these days
but in any case in this case your query
might be the full text of the birth
paper and the system might try to search
the acl anthology and the computational
language section of archive for similar
papers
to birth
recommendation is another key ir topic
in recommendation we still seek relevant
material from a large collection of
unstructured items but in this case the
user has no explicit query
and instead the previous interactions
enable the recommendation system to
suggest good matches
patent search
is yet another
ir task and unlike the others we've
mentioned so far it's often used by
experts not by average users and it has
very strong emphasis on hierarchical so
unlike the average web query where you
might be completely content
with one very good match at the top
patent search may need to find every
relevant patent to acquity or something
that approximates that
lastly even buying a new laptop can be
an ir problem and in particular a
conversational an ir problem
here the system may go in a back and
forth style between searching for
relevant products and asking the user
for their preferences about cost screen
quality and storage and other factors
on online e-commerce platforms
having looked at all of these ir tasks
it's important to keep in mind that each
of those tasks poses its own unique
challenges so even though we're always
interested in relevance and in finding
relevant items
each of those tasks
has its own
challenges and its own
components
to underscore this let's use web search
as a frame of reference while standard
web search might pose considerable
challenge when it comes to the massive
scale involved in terms of documents and
also queries
even something as seemingly mundane as
searching for conversations on your
slack workspace
often lacks key features that makes web
search tractable in the first place and
makes it work the way it does in the
first place
for one
so many web searches ask frequently
searched or head queries
the sheer popularity of headquarters
makes them an easy target for
large-scale
for large search engines
of course there's always a long tail of
rare search queries that still post
considerable challenge especially in
highly technical domains but it still
stands that in in a domain like web
search solving the the head queries gets
you
a very big part a very big share
of answering uh most user queries
as another factor web search enjoys
highly redundant
documents though out there that address
common topics where each document is
written in a slightly different way
this often shifts the search problem
into a precision one basically finding
some documents at least one that
definitely match the query as opposed to
at a cold one finding every document
that matches the query because there's
already too many of them
clearly this is not always the case if
you're looking for a very specific item
in your slack conversational history
yet another factor in web search is the
rich link structure that links between
existing related web pages
which again introduces you know more
hierarchy and might make this task more
tractable in practice
the idea here is definitely not
that web search is easy because it's not
easy but that the different tasks pose
different challenges for our ir systems
so that is ir
where does our work on nlu fit in ior
well of course quiz and documents are
often expressed in natural language at
least in part
so we naturally want to understand
equity's meaning and its intent
and understand the documents contents
and their topics to be able to
effectively match queries to documents
this form of understanding
is critical
although you can go pretty far for many
ir tasks with intelligently matching
terms at a lexical level
the vocabulary mismatch problem makes
this quite unattractive in practice
to explain
vocabulary mismatch happens when queries
and documents use different terms to
refer to the same thing
so i have here on the slide an example
query that shows this happening um in
practice
so the question is or the query is what
what what compounds protect the
digestive system against viruses
and the snippet that we are interested
in finding says in the stomach gastric
acid and proteases serve as powerful
chemical defenses against ingested
pathogens
you can see that the
passage that we found here uses
pathogens instead of viruses
which is a bit more general
stomach instead of digestive system
which is a bit more specific
and chemical instead of compounds and
defenses instead of protect but it's
pretty clear that it still answers the
same question and answers it very well
in fact
so where does nlu fit in ir
i guess a nice code here is jimmy lynn's
statement
jamilyn is an ir researcher who says ir
makes nlp useful and nlp makes ir
interesting
of course we do think nlp is useful
anyway and also ir is interesting anyway
so i added more between brackets here
but we do get jimmy's point
okay
on to our more central question where
does ir fit into our study of nlu and
how can i our service
in thinking about this i believe it's
helpful to appreciate that as our models
become more advanced in nlu
they too
like humans start to have complete
information needs in solving their tasks
more concretely retrieval can contribute
to our nlu tasks and systems in three
exciting ways
first
retrieval provides a rich source for
creating challenging and realistic
interview tasks ones where finding
information from a large corpus is
central
we will look closely at this bullet in
the remainder of these slides
second
retrieval offers a powerful tool to make
nlu models for existing tasks more
accurate and more effective we'll touch
upon this today but we'll discuss it in
more depth later
third
retrieval can often lend us a nice
framework for evaluating nlu systems
whenever the output domain is large just
just like in search
or whenever low latency is important
which are
key characteristics in ir we will expand
on this in a later screencast as well
in the remainder of this screencast
we'll explore how retrieval allows us to
pose very challenging and very realistic
open domain in a new tasks
chris has briefly introduced squad
before in the overview lecture
to remind you of this question answering
task the input that we are given in
squad is a context passage which was
obtained from wikipedia
and a question that tests our model's
understanding of this one passage
this is an interesting task on its own
right one that has enjoyed tons of work
and lots of recent progress
due to pre-trained language models
but with retrieval in mind we can move
from standard qa like squad to open
domain question answering
specifically in open domain question and
setting we can ask what if we want to
answer the same kinds of factoid
questions as quest as squad or other
types of questions
but without the perhaps unrealistic hint
of receiving the particular passage in
wikipedia that already contains the
answer
in this case we can take all of the
english wikipedia just as an example as
our context and then again again pose
the same question as squad over all of
wikipedia
and build models that can answer these
open questions over large corpora
so
how would we answer such questions
the literature in particular a nice
emnlp 2020 paper by robert setel
introduces a nice analogy for how we
might attempt to tackle this task and
how we could think about it
the first
perhaps more familiar and perhaps
simpler solution is to pose the question
to one of our usual transformers
and specifically to a generative
sequence to sequence model something
like t5 gpt2 or gpt3
in this case we're relying on the
knowledge stored internally and
implicitly in the model parameters
so the model memorizes these facts just
like you would do when you enter a
closed book exam
often this knowledge is memorized the
same way language is learned as a result
of language model pre-training or other
similar tasks
close book approaches to these
characteristically open domain problems
um offer a particularly consistent way
of improving quality and coverage well
just take your model train a larger
version of it on more data and hope that
that encodes more knowledge and gives
you more accurate
results
as an alternative to this
we could think about open book
approaches to open domain question
answering
so there's the analogy of doing an open
book exam
which tests not really your memory but
your awareness of where to look for
answers and how to use them quickly and
productively
in this case we would build what are
typically called retrieve and read
architectures
as shown at the bottom of the slide we
take the question and first feed it to a
retriever model
the retriever searches our collection of
facts in this case wikipedia as an
example
and extracts a bunch of passages or
other contexts that seem useful in
trying to answer the original question
these passages are then fed to a
downstream reader
so that could just be a small birth-like
model which studies these passages to
answer the original question
in this pipeline we've essentially
relied on this new retriever component
to reduce the original open domain
question answering problem to a much
smaller scale standard question
answering task
where the downstream model sees a
question and the relevant passage for a
few messages before extracting
a short answer
importantly we could say that the reader
in this architecture is a user that has
an information need and it's the
retriever's task to start to satisfy
this need accurately and efficiently
we will study various methods for
building retrievals in the subsequent
screencasts and look at how these
retrievers interact with downstream
breeders but for now let us just explore
some of the higher level differences
between open book and close book
solutions to open domain problems
our open book solutions often get to be
much smaller while being very accurate
still
the reason is that we've decoupled
knowledge from reasoning
and stored the knowledge outside the
model thus the model itself does not
need to store all of these facts inside
its parameters and it gets to be much
smaller as a result
as we will see later this has great
implications for efficiency
moreover the knowledge can be easily
updated by modifying the collection
as the facts in wikipedia for example
evolve over time
or alternatively suppose that you want
to switch from answering questions over
wikipedia to post to proposing questions
over the nlp literature or perhaps
posing question over the documentation
of your favorite software library
you can often
do that by simply swapping the
collection with a new one and keeping
the question answering model as is
in order to answer questions in this new
domain
lastly because we can see the actual
documents that are retrieved and the
documents that are read by the reader to
extract answers we're often better
positioned to explain how these models
know some facts or why they make
particular mistakes
on the downside though
all of a sudden we now need to worry
about the interactions between two
components the retriever and the reader
but i hope that the subsequent set of
screencasts will convince you that
working with retrievers in nlu is very
rewarding
all of this discussion so far has been
in the context of open domain question
answering
but there are many other interview tasks
that either inherently subsume retrieval
or at least can directly benefit from
interacting with a large collection of
relevant facts
one of those is claim verification or
fact checking
here the model receives this input a
disputed claim and his goal is to verify
or refute this claim and to return
documents that justify
its decision
two other tasks are query focused
summarization and informative dialogue
where we might also work with a large
collection of facts and given a topic or
in the context of a conversation
generate a useful summary of the
resources about that topic perhaps as
part of a conversation with a user
interested to learn about a new topic
lastly entity linking is a task that can
be posed over a large textual knowledge
base as well
given an utterance that refers to any
number of ambiguous entities or events
we should resolve this ambiguity and map
dimensions of these entities to their
descriptions
in a large knowledge base like wikipedia
so that would be
a form of entity linking
kilt or knowledge intensive language
tasks is a recent effort
aimed at collecting a number of
different data sets for retrieval-based
nlp incidentally all of these tasks in
kilt explicitly have a knowledge
component like answering a question or
verifying a claim
an open question in this exciting area
is whether retrieval can improve
performance for standard interview tasks
as well ones where the knowledge
challenge is less explicit
think for example sentiment analysis
natural language inference or any of the
other tasks we study so far
well this remains an open question but i
think that accurate knowledge matters
for most if not all of our language
tasks
and that converting many of these tasks
to an open book format or bring your own
book approach
may be a promising way to tackle these
tasks in practice
in the remainder of this unit we will
dig deeper into traditional methods and
metrics for information retrieval
and then explore recent advances in url
ir which will make a lot of use of our
nlu models like bert but in new and
creative ways
and then we will finally discuss open
domain question answering in more depth
as one of the most mature applications
of nau plus ir